[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a fallu quelques jours pour
que les gens se calment était déjà là
sa maison est fermée à clé et il va commencer comme
envie de réfléchir et de rencontrer votre
en couple ou seul et le besoin est né
de personnes à acheter ce type de
produits, l'augmentation a été
considérable environ 50 pour cent
pour cent de ce que nous venions habituellement
vente
[Musique]
bien qu'aussi comme le cherchait
le sujet des jouets sexuels en tant que
compléter de sorte que même si la flamme de
passion ou tout ce qui touche au sujet
le sexuel ne devient pas si monotone et
plus avec le thème du confinement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]